I think he could be a great NFL coach I
mean he has the work ethic he has the
passion for the game I know that I mean
he loves this sport and so I know he'd
be able to relate to quarterbacks and so
he would put in the work and now it's
about him finding out where he needs to
be it patrick mahomes talking about his
former college head coach Kliff
Kingsbury who was fired in November from
Texas Tech where he was 35 and 40 and
even with Patrick mahomes was not able
to put together strong teams gone lands
on his feet at USC and then a month
later he's now the head coach of the
Arizona Cardinals and this all happened
so quickly Chris and look I I don't know
what's gonna happen I don't know how
this is gonna play out but it just seems
odd when you look at the Cardinals
announcement they've revised it and
initially it said that Kings various
friends with Shawn McVeigh they've taken
that out because they realized they were
getting killed for that this idea that
we want anyone who's an offensive coach
who has any connection to Shawn McVeigh
it really is getting a little bit
ridiculous I'm not saying it doesn't
mean it's gonna fail or it means it's
gonna succeed I don't know that's
separate but the idea that teams are
trying to jam themselves into this Shawn
McVeigh narrative it's it's all it's a
little more than over-the-top at this
point extremely over-the-top I mean
first of all I think the fact that
they're trying to sell that he's friends
with Shawn McVeigh almost shows that
they're almost like trying to make up
reasons for why they are hiring him I
mean that to me that's the first funny
thing but yes to your point everybody's
looking for the next Shawn McVeigh and I
get that he's the man he's as smart as
it gets you know I call him kid genius
he's an extremely creative that's very
creative nickname yeah you know he's a
kid he's a genius let's call him kid
genius man he's a man but no regardless
he is an extremely impressive person and
I get teams wanting to you know copy
that and do that Kyle Shanahan same
thing the difference is and when I think
everybody's missing first of all is
these guys grew up in the NFL the
McVeigh's in the Shanahan's McVeigh was
the coach of a really offensive
coordinator of a really good offense
with the Washington Redskins after a few
years of being underneath Kyle Shanahan
who already had a plethora of top 5 and
top 10 offenses whether it was in
Houston Washington DC atlanta then he
goes there and does that so i think
that's the first thing that people don't
realize you know the college coach
genius okay there's two that always come
to my mind right away this offensive
college coach genius Steve Spurrier and
Chip Kelly how did that work out not
that great so I guess what I'm trying to
say here is yes I have doubts I do want
to say this Mike Kliff Kingsbury is he
is head coach material like he has the
potential to be a really good head coach
I've always thought that I've been
around cliff a bunch and he can lead men
and he can do all of those things but I
just think this is too premature at this
point coming from Texas Tech nobody in
college football really wanted to hire
him as a head coach and now you're gonna
make them the head coach of an NFL
football team because why they recruited
they recruited Patrick mahomes and Baker
Mayfield to their school you know that's
what I don't understand so yes I feel
this similar with this and the Matt
Lafleur hire the same thing guys got a
lot of qualities but this is way too
premature and I don't think they're
ready for this type of job Kliff
Kingsbury has been in coaching since
2008 he started as an offensive quality
control coach at the University of
Houston became the co-offensive
coordinator in quarterbacks coach 2012
the offensive coordinator and
quarterbacks coach at Texas A&M and then
was the head coach at Texas Tech through
2018 from 2013 through 2018 35 and 40
was his record and fired hired by USC as
offensive coordinator and became the
subject of kind of a tug of war between
the Cardinals and the Jets although I
think it was always Kingsbury to the
Cardinals now that the dust has settled
on it and and yeah it's it's obvious in
the announcement they mentioned Sean
mcveigh's and offensive genius and they
they touted the connection between
Kingsbury and McVeigh and again they've
taken that that language out because
they got killed ruthless
right it is it's it's just it and again
I don't want to say it means he's gonna
fail he can end up being highly
successful right these jobs are very few
and far between and there's a certain
level of credential I think you need to
have to be a viable candidate and Kliff
Kingsbury isn't there yet he's not even
remotely close to being there and this
may help him Chris I was talking about
this on the radio side with Chip Kelly
when he finally became the coach of the
Eagles in 2013 that was after years of
courtship and we had gotten accustomed
to the idea that Chip Kelly's eventually
gonna come to the NFL just like when
spur
spur is finally coming to the NFL's
nick-san is finally coming to the
failures of bombing the college ranks
right I mean right that right right but
but that so the bar was high for them
this is the one positive for Kingsbury
and the Cardinals because Kingsbury's
just popping up out of the blue and
we're all saying oh this is bad this
isn't gonna work it's premature the bar
is low and that's a good thing
it is the bar is naturally going to
congratulations Cardinals you have
managed in just a few short years to
take the bar from here all the way down
to here but if the bar is gonna be any
where you want it to be low that's the
one positive that comes out of this for
the Cardinals and for Kingsbury because
nobody's gonna expect anything because
everyone's gonna say exactly what we're
saying now it's too early he's not ready
it's not gonna work and so if they go
six and ten the first year that's a
pretty good year yes I mean no doubt
about that and the fact that it is a low
bar is great all right but again you
know I this is what I would call a hope
higher this is a hope higher oh I I hope
this works out I mean he looks good at
the podium and you know he he's he's got
great charisma and good people skills
that way I hope he turns into Shawn
McVeigh I hope I hope and I feel like
the same thing with Matt Lafleur you
know I'll go back to the the wouldn't
with Kingsbury I really do think he has
the potential to be a really good head
coach but I don't know if this is gonna
be the best thing for him to really
maximize his potential you know I'll go
back to something I say to you a lot I
don't think he knows what he or he
doesn't know what he doesn't know you
you know what I'm saying there because
he's been basically in one offensive
system his whole life now I know he got
one year on the practice squad with the
New England Patriots and maybe a
training camp with the New Orleans
Saints
you're not gonna digest the entirety of
those two offenses because you hung
around for a year or a few months I've
watched film a Patrick mahomes coming
out in the draft I cover games with
Kliff Kingsbury was the head coach and
Baker Mayfield was the quarterback down
there and he wasn't even sure if Baker
Mayfield should be the starter at that
time just to point that out to everybody
he was favoring Davis Webb so they were
going back and forth between that but it
is a college offense yes and I would say
when I break it down you know there's
this has got limitations Mike it's not
like you break this offense go down and
go oh man look at all these formations
and different concepts they do know it's
great pace they get to the line of
scrimmage quickly but the concepts are
kind of simple and they just try to
spread you out and throw it all over the
field and and as we've seen with the
other guys that you talked about
Spurrier Chip Kelly
you know after defensive coordinators
got to see the offense once or twice or
just acquired a little film man did they
start to sputter out in a hurry
and by the way Baker Mayfield will have
an opportunity to stare down Kliff
Kingsbury this season 2019 Browns at
Cardinals so put that one on the
primetime list of preferred games this
year as well
look what with with with Kingsbury and
Mahone because I think it's the
combination of being friends with Sean
McVeigh and being responsible for
Patrick mahomes right but when when we
consider where the world was two years
ago as the draft was approaching mahomes
wasn't regarded as the must-have
can't-miss guy if we knew now yeah our
then what is it we knew then we know now
about mahomes he would have been the
number one pick and and I'm saying all
this because Kingsbury didn't draw out
of him the things that Andy Reid is
drawn out of him and and he came into
the NFL as a much less polished product
and that's a result of the coaching he
got or didn't get from from Kliff
Kingsbury yeah people were scared you
know when I you know at the time and the
Holmes is coming out I was doing draft
video
that bleacher report talking about
Patrick mahomes and I think he's the
best quarterback in the draft and he's
really special
I had NFL people and everybody going
you're crazy
that's just a Texas Tech you're looking
at yards and I'm like no sorry I mean
this guy made the offense go I think
that's the big thing again I think this
is the thing I really like Kliff
Kingsbury I want to make that point
clear and I am a believer in him I don't
think this is really gonna be like I'm
saying gonna be the best thing for his
career ultimately I would have loved to
have seen him go maybe be the OC at USC
for a few years if you really wanted to
dabble in the NFL he could have gotten
off that's a coordinator job here in the
next year or two anyways we've we've
heard that when he got fired from Texas
Tech Andy Reed wanted to bring him in as
a consultant
Sean McVeigh wanted to bring him in as a
consultant they want to pick his brain
if you steal a few ideas from him and I
think he could have grown into something
really special under the tutelage of
those guys with the offense he already
has in the back of his mind so you know
again I'm not faulting Kliff Kingsbury
for taking the job because there's only
thirty two of these and you don't know
if you'll ever be offered one again so
good for him but I'm just saying right
now I think organizations and teams are
not hiring necessarily the best
candidates that are out there for the
head coaching position they're all just
going oh
quarterback whisperer he was with good
quarterbacks all he must be good that's
that's all there is at the end of the
day and there's just more to that and I
think there was other options out here
where you could have played along and
maybe hired a defensive coach who could
have brought in a great offensive
coordinator that's all I'm saying here I
don't want to go too hard on cliff
because I do see a lot of positive
attributes there yeah but you're making
a good point and I think even he was
surprised by this otherwise he wouldn't
have taken the USC job
Brian early December if he knew he was
gonna be in play for NFL head coaching
jobs he waits it out because it isn't a
good look III don't have any problem
with him leaving USC Peter King and I
argued about this yesterday cuz Peter
thinks it's not the honorable thing to
do and I said there's no honor in
college football so it doesn't matter
yeah right but but he wouldn't taken
that job if he knew he was going to be
seriously in play and on that short list
and and it tells me that so much of
these decisions are being made by the
seat-of-the-pants
they really are and and and owners
and see they get desperate and they just
say ah screw it let's just do it let's
go get our Sean McVeigh
I'd rather get our Sean McVeigh than not
get our Sean McVeigh if this guy stinks
we can just fire him like we fired Steve
Loucks and go hire somebody else exactly
right and I'll throw another leg you
know just the little thing out here food
for thought is this you know GM's
okay when they make these decisions GM's
are good at evaluating players there's
no doubt about that
Steve Kimes had some great free agent
signings and some great draft picks and
all that I get that same with our guy in
Green Bay but at the end of the day I
forgot what I was going to say there
hold on I just blanked out on what I was
gonna say that's fine but you think
about what you're gonna say because we
should take a break at this one anyway I
love your honesty and by the way
speaking of Hope hires you were a hope
hire and you're still a hope hire
year-and-a-half later
Oh
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports